[engine running]
[music playing]
Well, season 2
on "Truck Night,"
we tried to ramp it up a little
bit with some new challenges.
And one of our favorite
is Creek Climb.
It's a cool little creek that
tests your truck's suspension.
Man, you can see that
thing articulate.
[engine roaring]
And then we hit
some gnarly climbs.
That first climb's
at 60 degrees.
And then the second
climb is at 70 degrees.
And we made it even
a little nastier.
We threw some
water on top of it.
It's super cool.
Let's take a look at it.
Go!
Nice and slow.
A little slower.
No, no, no, turn my way.
My way, driver.
See, if you can
see, it's hard to get
those tires to
stick on the rocks
because it's so damn slippery.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
[crash]
Oh!
You've got to really drive it
high up onto Glen's left there
to get the front end around it.
And then the rear end
kind of settles in.
If you don't, you
end up on your side,
right in the middle
of this creek bed.
[music playing]
And then you go
into the bends.
So you've got to carry a high
line here so that you can make
it around that next
bend there and maintain
the high side on this one.
Because the last turn out
of here gets real tight.
Run up and over
it and to the right.
There you go.
A little more right,
a little more right.
Get down in the pond.
Nice work.
Once the driver comes
out the creek part,
now it's time to
do the climb part.
[engine roaring]
This is where it's really
crucial to pick a good line.
Perfect, perfect, perfect.
[engine roaring]
ROB PARK: To try
and pull momentum
and not have the tires
leave the ground--
Woo!
--that's really key
in this challenge.
Woo!
That's what I'm
talking about, Zach!
Nailed it!
Yeah!
ABE WINE: Killer job.
So that's a look
at the creek climb.
We love it.
I know a lot of the other
drivers have loved it.
[engine roaring]
You guys wanted it.
You wanted some rocks.
Kicking it up for season 2.
[music playing]
PETE SOHREN: This
is the Slag Heap.
And it tests your truck's speed.
So you're looking at a climb
of about 100 vertical feet
at a 45-degree angle.
But you have to climb
over a bunch of logs
to get to the finish line.
The key to this challenge
is when to be on the gas
and when to be on the brakes.
Slag Heap is one of
our toughest challenges
here on "Truck Night."
Every one of those trucks had
the power to get up this hill.
But driver error kept three
of them from making it.
Ready, set, go!
[engines roaring]
Oh, look at the little
red one on the far side.
All you got to do to
get up the Slag Hill
is maintain traction.
We had one driver
on the outside lane
barely spin a tire
going up the hill.
We had every other driver
throwing big rooster tails.
They looked like boats
going across the water.
PETE SOHREN: The
little red Ford's gonna
make it up the hill first.
GLEN PLAKE: Go, little red!
Do it, buddy!
Do it!
Yeah!
Little red takes it.
Let's come over the lane 2 here.
Look at the two big
holes dug in right there
in front of that log.
Instead of backing
up, resetting,
he just spin the tires, spin
the tires, spin the tires.
And then he broke something.
[engine roaring]
[crash]
Oh, my gosh.
[bleep]
You come over the
lane 3, you got four,
six big holes on those logs.
Back up, reset.
You know?
This challenge-- you don't have
to win, you've got to finish.
Everything on "Truck Night,"
you don't have to win.
You've got to finish, especially
in these early challenges.
[engine roaring]
Do it!
Go, go, yeah!
MAN: There you go, buddy!
Look over here.
We kind of got a mess.
Looks like a rototiller has been
going up there because they've
just been turning and burning.
Big, giant motors, it causes
a lack of traction problem
if not done correctly.
[engines roaring]
[creaking]
Oh, no!
Stop, stop!
It's over!
Wow!
These five lanes tell
the story of Slag Heap.
I've got two clean
lanes, and I've got three
lanes where people got stuck.